à l'été les belles soirées chaudes à
observer les étoiles
au fait c'est quoi vraiment une étoile
dans une fameuse scène du roi lion timon
et pumbaa avaient chacun une hypothèse
c'est quoi les lucioles combat un genre
de verre qui reste collé sur cette
espèce de machin bleu marine
tiens moi je pensais que c'était des
bulles de gaz qui brûlait à des millions
de kilomètres de nous
toi à part le gaz y a pas grand-chose
qui t'intéresse alors évidemment vous
dit certainement que c'est pullback à
raison une bulle de gaz qui brûle et
pourtant on va voir aujourd'hui pourquoi
une étoile n'est pas franchement une
bulle
pourquoi ça n'est pas vraiment du gaz
non plus et surtout pourquoi ça ne brûle
pas dû
[Musique]
la première chose à dire c'est que les
étoiles ne sont pas nés au moment du big
bang elles se sont formées
progressivement et pour comprendre
comment une étoile fonctionne eh ben
c'est important de remonter à sa
naissance
vous savez certainement qu'il existe
plus d'une centaine d'éléments dans le
tableau de mendeleïev et pourtant au
moment du big bang et bien l'univers a
vraiment fait les choses au minimum
puisqu'il n'a créé que de l'hydrogène
l'élément le plus simple un proton un
électron et un peu d'hélium
ces atomes qui ont été produits dans les
premières minutes du big bang se
retrouve aujourd'hui accumulé en immense
nuage de gaz comme ce convoi représente
et sur ces belles images
alors il y aurait beaucoup à dire sur
comment ces nuages sont arrivés là et
pourquoi certaines régions de l'univers
en ont plus que d'autres mais ce sera
pour une prochaine vidéo
ce qui est important pour notre sujet
c'est que ces nuages de gaz ont au
départ une densité ridiculement faible
au mieux quelques dizaines d'atomes par
centimètre cube
mais comme la seule force à laquelle ils
soient soumis c'est leur propre gravité
eh bien ces atomes satire entre eux et
le nuages commencent à se contracter
progressivement
alors c'est très très faible comme force
a donc ça prend des millions d'années
mais bon à l'échelle de l'univers c'est
pas le temps qui manque
quand un nuage se contracte sa densité
augmente
et quand elle devient suffisamment
importante les atomes d'hydrogène
s'associent pour former des molécules h2
du dihydrogène on parle alors de nuages
moléculaires et ce sont dans ces nuages
que les étoiles vont pouvoir mettre des
nuages qu'on appelle parfois
poétiquement des pouponnières des toiles
si vous voulez en voir une belle il y à
la nébuleuse d'orion située dans la
constellation du même nom alors les
visites plutôt en hiver et même si vous
ne la verrez pas aussi bien que ça le
spectacle est déjà très beau avec une
simple paire de jumelles
le point essentiel c'est que dans ces
nuages au fur et à mesure de
l'effondrement
la pression et la température augmente
pas ses 3000 degrés les molécules de
dihydrogène se casse en deux puis entre
6000 et 10 mille degrés les électrons et
les protons qui constituent les atomes
d'hydrogène commencent à se séparer
on se retrouve alors avec ce qu'on
appelle plasma est donc techniquement ce
n'est plus un gaz comme le prétendait
pumba mais un plasma qu'on appelle
parfois le quatrième état de la matière
en plus des trois classiques solides
liquides et gaz
cette phase d'effondrement et
d'échauffement peut durer des centaines
de milliers d'années et à ce stade on
n'a pas encore une étoile qui brille
le de protoétoile sauf qu'au bout d'un
moment et bien la température au centre
du nuage de plasma devient vraiment
élevé et quand elles dépassent 10
millions de degrés l'étoile peut
s'allumer et on va voir ce que ça veut
dire vraiment que ça lui mais quand on
m'a dit qu'une étoile brûle savait pas
vraiment correct ce qui se passe dans
une étoile ce n'est pas une combustion
qui serait une réaction chimique mais il
s'agit d'une fusion c'est à dire une
réaction thermonucléaire des atomes
d'hydrogène fusionnent pour donner des
atomes d'hélium
cette réaction de fusion c'est celle
qu'on retrouve dans l'explosion des
bombes h et qu'on aimerait bien arriver
à contrôler dans une centrale pour
produire de l'énergie nucléaire par
fusion plutôt que par fission c'est
notamment le but du projet iter dont
vous voyez ici une photo mais comme
certains le font remarquer
malicieusement on possède déjà une belle
centre à la fusion nucléaire disponibles
pas loin de chez nous c'est le soleil
qui est une étoile évidemment un et donc
brille grâce à la fusion gelé dit pour
que la réaction de fusion s'enclenche
il faut une température minimum de 10 à
15 millions de degrés alors ça peut
paraître un peu bizarre qu'il faille
d'abord chauffer pour ensuite produire
de la chaleur mais pour le coup bah ça
marche comme les réactions chimiques de
combustion de même qu'il vous faut une
allumette pour démarrer un feu et bien
il faut de la chaleur pour initier une
fusion nucléaire
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que la fusion
de l'hydrogène en hélium ne peut se
produire que dans la zone la plus chaude
des étoiles qu'on appelle le coeur ou le
noyau c'est le centre de l'étoile et qui
pour le soleil ne représente que 1 % de
son volume
non mais quand même 30 % de sa masse
cette réaction de fusion hydrogène donne
hélium
je vous en parle comme si elle était
simple mais en fait elle n'est pas du
tout une première chose qu'il faut noter
c'est que le noyau de l'atome
d'hydrogène c'est juste un proton alors
que celui de l'hélium ces deux protons
et de neutrons déjà ça fait quatre
composants mais surtout d'où ils
viennent les neutrons et bien ils
viennent d'une capacité qu'ont les
protons de se transformer en neutrons
alors voici le schéma complet de la
réaction de fusion
d'abord deux noyaux d'hydrogène de
protons fusionnent puis l'un des protons
se transforme en neutrons grâce à ce
qu'on appelle une désintégration bêta et
en émettant un positron et un neutrino
on obtient alors du deutérium qui est de
l'hydrogène avec un neutron en plus
petit aparté sur les trucs qui ont été
émis au passage le positron et le
neutrino le positron c'est un anti
électrons c'est de l'anti matière et il
va aller se désintégrer avec le premier
électrons qui lui passe sous la main en
produisant du rayonnement donc de la
chaleur quant aux neutrinos et d'un vous
savez peut-être que c'est une particule
qui a la spécificité de ne presque pas
interagir avec le reste de la matière et
donc il va s'échapper du soleil et
partir à la conquête du système solaire
et à l'heure où vous m'écoutez ce sont
environ 5000 milliards de neutrinos qui
traverse votre corps à chaque seconde en
provenance directe du soleil
mais revenons à notre réaction de fusion
on a produit du deutérium donc se
détériore absorbe à nouveau un proton et
devient de l'hélium 3 avec un seul
neutrons et quand de zélium trois
produits de cette façon se rencontrent
ils peuvent fusionner pour donner un
hélium 4 la forme de l'hélium la plus
courante qui contient deux neutrons et
tout ça en rejetant au passage deux
protons hawaï et que le processus de
fusion de l'hydrogène en hélium est
quand même assez compliqué on appelle ça
la chaîne de réactions proton proton et
quand je dis que la réaction est
compliqué ça n'est pas seulement qu'il
ya beaucoup d'étapes mais que les
réactions ne se produise pas facilement
alors certes au centre d'une étoile on a
plein de protons qui se tape les uns
avec les autres à 15 millions de degrés
et pourtant la fusion reste un phénomène
assez rare et donc la réaction n'est pas
très efficace sur ce sujet je vous
recommande la vidéo de l'excellente
chaîne je m'énerve pages explique qu'ils
nous montrent à quel point certaines
étapes de la chaîne proton proton sont
compliquées et comment tout ça finit par
fonctionner uniquement grâce à une chose
l'effet tunnel une petite illustration
du fait que la réaction fusion n'est pas
très efficace
regardez cette courbe elle vous montre
la puissance dégagée par un mètre cube
de soleil en fonction de la position par
rapport au centre dans les couches
extérieures c'est zéro je vous ai dit
tout se passe dans le noyau cette courbe
nous dit que même si vous pré levier un
mètre cube de plasma dans le noyau pour
le mettre au béton dans votre salon eh
bien il vous fournirait une énergie que
de quelques dizaines à quelques
centaines de watts en moyenne beaucoup
moins efficace qu'une cheminée ou un
radiateur et heureusement d'ailleurs
parce que si la fusion dans les étoiles
étaient plus efficaces et bien elle
aurait épuisé tous leurs hydrogène en
quelques millions d'années seulement
et on serait pas là pour
allez vous expliquer tout à l'heure que
les réactions de fusion nucléaire ne se
produisait que dans le coeur de l'étoile
là où il fait suffisamment chaud on peut
se demander pourquoi à force de
s'effondrer tout les poils n'atteint pas
la température suffisante pour que la
fusion se produisent partout et bien la
raison c'est que quand l'étoile démarre
sa fusion l'effondrement fini par
s'arrêter au sein d'une étoile qui
brille il règne une forme d' équilibre
d'un côté la gravité pousse les toiles à
s'effondrer sur elle-même comme le
faisait le nuage de gaz qui va donner
naissance et de l'autre comme les zones
au centre sont plus chaudes
la pression est plus importante et va
contrebalancer la force de gravité il
existe plusieurs équations qui décrivent
les phénomènes qui se produisent dans
une étoile et qui permettent de
comprendre cet équilibre alors je vais
pas vous les détailler mais sachez
qu'elles permettent de calculer par
exemple la densité la température la
pression ou encore la luminosité en
fonction de la distance au centre de
l'étoile
voici une représentation de ces
quantités pour le cas du soleil et il ya
quelques points intéressants qu'on peut
noter dont la masse volumique tout
d'abord augmente au fur et à mesure
qu'on s'approche du centre assez logique
en plein coeur elle atteint 160 tonnes
par mètre cube
ce qui est beaucoup mais pas non plus
démentiel seulement huit fois plus que
le métal le plus dense qu'on connaisse
l'osmium la température elle varie
environs de 16 millions de degrés au
centre jusqu'à seulement 5500 degrés à
la surface quant à la puissance cumulée
de dégager un conte appelle la
luminosité
elle est de près de 400 millions de
milliards de giga watts alors par
comparaison une centrale électrique
aujourd'hui c'est maxi quelques giga
watts une chose intéressante que l'on
peut déduire en manipulant les équations
qui décrivent le fonctionnement d'une
étoile c'est que la température et la
luminosité de l'étoile sont toujours
liées entre elles et ne dépendent que
d'une chose la masse de l'étoile vous
voyez ici un petit diagramme dans lequel
on peut représenter pour chaque étoile
sa température de surface en abscisses
et sa luminosité en ordonner à noter de
choses pour des raisons historiques
on représente l'échelle des températures
allant vers les plus élevés sont à
gauche et aussi les échelles sur les
deux axes sont logarithmique si je place
le soleil
il se trouve ici maintenant imaginez une
étoile disons 50 % plus massif que le
soleil on peut calculer sa température
et
la luminosité grâce aux équations et
elle se retrouverait ici à trois fois la
masse du soleil ce serait là et puis 6
10 ou 30 fois plus dans ce coin-là plus
une étoile est massive plus sa
luminosité et sa température sont
importantes
inversement si je prends des étoiles
moins massif que le soleil est bien
elles seront de moins en moins lumineuse
est de moins en moins chaudes en surface
ce que je vous ai tracé là ce sont des
résultats de calcul 1 obtenue avec des
équations
mais ce sont aussi des choses qu'on peut
mesurer en observant des vraies étoiles
la luminosité d'une étoile peut se
déduire en mesurant sa brillance ce
qu'on appelle la magnitude et en
connaissant sa distance à nous pour la
température de surface c'est plus subtil
elle est reliée à sa couleur plus une
étoile et bleu plus elle est chaude
tandis que plus à l'est rouge plus elle
est froide en observant la couleur d'une
étoile
on peut estimer sa température de
surface alors notez quand même une chose
un contrairement aux liens qu'on fait
dans le langage de tous les jours pour
une étoile
le bleu est une couleur chaude et le
rouge une couleur froide et donc si on
place tout un tas des toiles connues
dans le diagramme luminosité température
voici ce qu'on obtient ce graphique on
l'appelle le diagramme hr pour hertz
prom russell qu'ils ont chacun imaginait
indépendamment au début du 20e siècle
prenons quelques étoiles connues allez
altaïr dans la constellation de l'aigle
camp était vous pouvez voir à peu près
au dessus de vos têtes
eh bien elle est ici dans le diagramme
spica dans la constellation de la vierge
visible vers l'ouest en début de soirée
se trouve là quant à proxima du centaure
vous savez l'étoile la plus proche de
nous et autour de laquelle on a
découvert une exoplanète en 2016 eh bien
elle se trouve ici c'est ce qu'on
appelle une naine rouge
sa température en surface n'est que de
3000 degrés sa masse un dixième de celle
du soleil et sa luminosité dix mille
fois plus faible pas du tout le même
genre des toiles que le soleil donc tout
ça est très bien on a un bel accord
entre les équations qui nous permettent
de calculer la luminosité et la
température de surface de l'étoile est
ce qu'on peut en observer des grosses
étoiles bleues des petites étoiles
rouges et des étoiles intermédiaire
blanche jaune et pourtant il faut quand
même que je vous avoue une chose je vous
cache une partie de la vérité
il existe dans le ciel d'autres étoiles
qui ne colle pas dans ce schéma
[Musique]
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
des étoiles qu'on appelle les géantes
rouges ou bien les naines blanches
elle se situe ici et là dans le
diagramme pas du tout au même endroit
que les autres toutes les étoiles dont
on a parlé avant que l'on trouve dans la
diagonale du milieu ont dit qu'elles
sont dans la séquence principale et
cette séquence principale c'est
uniquement pour les étoiles disons à
l'âge adulte
quand les étoiles commence à vieillir
d'autres phénomènes que ce dont j'ai
parlé commencent à se dérouler à
l'intérieur et c'est ça qui va provoquer
des changements à partir du moment où
elle s'est allumé une étoile fusionnent
l'hydrogène situé dans son coeur mais de
fait il y en a de moins en moins de
disponible et quand tout son coeur s'est
transformé en hélium et bien la fusion
s'arrête
sauf que je vous avais dit qu'une étoile
obéit à un équilibre
l'énergie dégagée par la fusion permet
de contrebalancer l'effondrement
gravitationnel est donc quand il n'ya
plus d'hydrogène disponible dans le
noyau est bien l'effondrement en reprend
le temps que l'étoile mais a épuisé tous
l'hydrogène de son coeur dépend de sa
masse initiale
sauf que plus une étoile est massive
plus la réaction de fusion est rapide et
donc il se passe un truc contre intuitif
ce sont les étoiles les plus grosses qui
vivent le moins longtemps ce diagramme
représente ce temps approximatif qu'une
étoile passe dans la séquence principale
en fonction de sa masse c'est une
échelle logarithmique un toujours pour
une étoile comme le soleil cela dure
environ dix milliards d'années alors vu
que le soleil n'est âgé que de 4,5
milliards d'années
il n'en est en gros qu'à la moitié de sa
vie d'adulte donc on a le temps mais une
étoile ayant 40 fois la masse du soleil
ne passera que quelques millions
d'années dans la séquence principale
avant de commencer sa phase de
vieillissement pour les étoiles plus
légères c'est tout le contraire
à tel point qu'une étoile comme proxima
du centaure une naine rouge presque dix
fois moins massif que le soleil pourrait
très bien rester là encore mille
milliards d'années soit 70 fois l'âge
actuel de l'univers on voit que pour les
étoiles la durée de vie n'est vraiment
pas la même pour tout le monde et le
destin non plus d'ailleurs
alors voyons un peu ce qui se passe on
l'a dit une fois l'hydrogène du coeur
épuisé l'étoile reprend sa contraction
et la température à l'intérieur augmente
à nouveau à tel point que l'hydrogène
des couches autour du noyau fini par
atteindre le seuil suffisant pour
fusionner à son tour et du fait de
l'augmentation de pression les couches
encore plus extérieur se retrouve elle
repoussait
donc vu de loin l'étoile enfle devient
très grosse mais sa température de
surface
elle diminue grosses étoiles mais plus
froide en surface et bien voici où elle
se retrouve dans le diagramme hr c'est
ce qu'on appelle une géante rouge des
étoiles de ce type il y en a plusieurs
dans le ciel par exemple aldebaran dans
la constellation du taureau
une fois arrivé à ce stade ça devient
compliqué car l'évolution d'une étoile
va pouvoir suivre plusieurs chemins
notamment suivant sa masse on sait que
quand la température du coeur devient
encore plus élevé proche du milliard de
degrés
l'hélium qui s'y étaient accumulés va à
son tour se mettre à fusionner pour
produire du carbone
l'énergie ainsi libéré permet de
redonner en quelque sorte une seconde
jeunesse à l'étoile et dans certains cas
le carbone peut à son tour fusionner en
oxygène pour les étoiles plus massive on
peut même avoir production d'éléments
plus lourd du tableau périodique comme
le néon le sodium magnésium etc dans le
cas du soleil on pense qu'il finira par
expulser la majorité de ces couches
extérieures pour ne laisser qu'un tout
petit noyau chaud et brillant dans
lequel la fusion aura cessé ce qu'on
appelle une naine blanche
si on visualise ces changements dans le
diagramme hr le soleil passera donc de
là à la puis à la barre il y aurait
encore beaucoup à dire sur les destins
des étoiles parce que suivant les
circonstances certaines deviendront des
étoiles à neutrons des trous noirs ou
exploseront en supernova mais ça nous
amènerait un peu loin
si tout cela vous intéresse je vous
recommande la chaîne le sense of wonder
qui a notamment traité de la mort du
soleil et des supernova voilà c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur ce que j'ai raconté je
donne plein de petits détails dans le
billet de blog qui accompagne la vidéo
comme d'habitude et comme toujours
laïque et partager la cloche tout ça
facebook et twitter c'est pour les actus
de la chaîne et on se retrouve très vite
pour des nouvelles vidéos à bientôt
[Musique]